- Today on Drew.
Get the story behind the scenes.
- Tell her to unmute.
- Can you hear us?
- Of season one surprises.
The gag was all David's idea.
And
we reveal our very first celebrity guest
and she is a very good friend.
It all starts now.
(upbeat music)
- [Announcer] Please
welcome Drew Barrymore!
- Hi everybody, welcome!
The season two premiere
of the Drew Barrymore show
is less than a week away.
September 13th, check your local listings
or go to the drewbarrymoreshow.com.
Go to Show Finder, type in your zip code
(fingers snap) and boom
you'll find out right away.
I couldn't be more excited.
We're kicking things off
with a huge LA premiere.
I'm going back to the town that made me
for a whole week of Hollywood shows
because there's no place like home.
And then I'm returning to
my new home here in New York
for another week of New
York city Premier shows
the week of September 20th.
It's 10 days of celebrating our roots
and we'll be highlighting home
towns all across the country.
Maybe even yours?
Go ahead back to the website,
drewbarrymoreshow.com and let
us know why your home town
is special, to you.
But before we get to all of that,
we've got this great round
up of our favorite moments
from season one, with some bonus content.
A little behind the
scenes commentary from me
on what really went down.
So let's kick it off,
with a moment that will
stay with me forever.
My producers and the whole
team planned a birthday show
for me and I wasn't in on one detail.
I asked, "Please don't tell me anything.
I don't want to know.
I don't think you're gonna do anything
but whatever you do, I'll
just, you know, not know."
And then all of a sudden
there were surprises
and gosh, you wouldn't
even believe who showed up.
I didn't even know if
there would be anyone here,
but guess who came?
David Letterman.
Someone who is very much
inextricably linked in my history
and he came in-studio,
in-person during the pandemic.
So it meant all the more.
And he wished me happy birthday
and birthdays were kind of
a thing between him and I.
Anyway, uh, take a look.
- I'm gonna give you some clues.
Okay?
- Okay.
- Let's see how you would do.
He would be on your top 10 list of guests,
I think you'd want at any party.
You once surprised him on his birthday.
- Oh my God.
- And his stupid human trick
- David.
- is being one, the greatest
television hosts of all time.
Do you know who this might be?
- I know exactly who it is.
- Who is it?
- David Letterman.
- Let us welcome David Letterman, hi Dave!
(audience applauding)
- Hi everybody!
Hi Drew!
Happy birthday!
Savannah, hello, how are you?
- Hi, she's dying, she can't believe it!
- Oh my gosh!
- Can you hear me?
- I'm having a hard time
catching my breath, I can hear you!
Dave!
- I can't, I can't hear her.
- Oh, Dave--
- Is there a filter?
- Wait.
- Do you have a filter on?
I can't, tell her to unmute!
Could you unmute? (laughter)
- Are you zooming, Dave?
What's like, are you good at technology--
- I'm not a cat, I can't,
I'm sorry I can't hear her.
- Well you look like a fine cat.
- Can you hear me?
- Okay, it's the thought
that counts, Dave!
- Yes, we can hear you!
- We hear you but can you hear us?
- [Dave] Forget it, forget it.
Forget that.
- Can you believe, I mean that's
so sweet of him to do that.
- I know!
- When was the last time
you actually saw Dave?
- I feel the same
way he does about Zoom.
Especially when my daughters crash--
(upbeat music)
(crowd cheering)
- Hi everybody.
How are you?
Hi Savannah!
- Hi Dave!
- How are you?
- Hi!
- You look wonderful!
Nice to see you, happy birthday!
What do you think?
Here, sit down.
Oh my!
- (sobbing) I'm--
(Dave laughing)
- We're going to need the tissues.
- I'm so grateful that you came here.
- Let me tell you something.
You know that a little trick
with the computer and stuff?
That Zoomer thing?
That was my idea!
- That was good, you still got it!
- Oh thank you!
- It was really effective,
I really thought, I was like,
"Okay, Dave, I get it too!"
- You're actually crying!
Oh that breaks my heart, God bless you.
- I'm so grateful that
you are showing up for me.
- I can't thank you enough for everything
and the friendship that
you demonstrated for us
when we were on the show and
it meant a great deal then,
and this means a great deal as well.
Happy birthday, and thank you
for, or did I invite myself?
- No!
- I don't know how this happened.
- You're this, you're
kind of the guest of honor
next to Drew, but wait--
- The poor dear is actually crying.
- She's crying, she's shocked.
I told her, she really
thought she might know
who was coming--
- I love you, I really do!
- Well I love you as well!
- Okay, wait, hold on, this is so weird.
It's Drew's birthday,
I'm Savannah Guthrie.
I'm here to celebrate Drew.
Oh, just David Letterman,
swinging by to shock Drew.
I don't think surprise is
the word, I think it's shock.
- And I kept saying she has to know.
This woman is a seasoned
show business veteran
in front of the camera, behind
the camera in her office,
anywhere want to put her, she
has to know this is going on.
And then you come out
here and you're crying
and that was so touching and
very sweet of you, thank you.
- I'm just so honored
that you show up for me.
I mean it, because I feel
even weird saying "Up for me,"
I'm just so happy to see
you as an old friend.
- It's been a long time.
I know it's not my show to produce,
but how great would this be
if it was really a surprise
for Savannah Guthrie?
Ladies and gentleman!
- If I just got up
on this table and you know,
in fact, I think we should
roll a certain clip.
- Get off the furniture!
- I mean, what is going on?
- Would you like me to do a dance for you?
(crowd cheering)
- What?
- Hey Paul!
Hi Paul, Paul gimme some blues!
- Oh my god.
- Oh, oh my goodness.
- I... that happened.
Dave, do you remember that?
Anything about that?
- I'll tell you, honestly,
I used to watch old movies.
Blackboard Jungle, Glenn Ford,
and what happens is the
juvenile delinquent teenagers
take over the classroom and
they're up on Glenn Ford's desk
and they're going to beat him up.
And so Drew is there, I love
the "Hi Paul." (girl laughing)
And then she climbs up on the
desk and I thought to myself,
"Oh no, I've lost control
of the class!" (laughter)
And then my next thought was,
"I think I'm probably
going to get kicked."
And then everything changed.
You know, like in The Wizard of Oz,
when it goes from black
and white to color,
that's what it was like.
- I had no plan of doing that,
it was one of those moments
in my life where I felt like
a magnet was pulling me
and it was all very playful
and well-intended, and I just had no idea
where it was going.
And I almost was like,
"Should I be embarrassed?
Did I do something bad?
Am I in trouble?"
And I knew in that
moment that with one turn
you could have gone, "Why did you do that?
What's wrong with you?"
And instead you had that smile
and you said to everyone,
"This moment is okay."
(laughter)
- Oh my God, oh my God!
- That was the moment.
I hope that I can be half
the man Dave is right now
and just let something
innocent and spontaneous
be innocent and spontaneous.
- Well, I recognized it
immediately is being unique.
It had not happened prior
to me has not happened
since to me, and later I was thinking,
"Oh geez, now what if she goes
and does this on Leno show,
then I'll really be upset."
But it was kind of a connection
for us throughout our,
the rest of our existence here.
- You compelled me in
a moment to take a risk
and you allowed it to be
paid off with kindness
and reciprocity and goodness and humor,
which is my ultimate.
Honestly, I think that's
the greatest award
and reward that people can
give each other in life.
- Oh, later we were, of course, married--
- Yes, we went to a
church and got married.
Look at me, I'm like,
I think you're so cute.
I did, I've had a crush on you forever so.
- We were happy for
another 20 minutes there.
- That's right, like a normal marriage.
- Drew was on your show 20 times.
- 20 times, that's remarkable.
- That's got to be one of your
best guests.
- Well again, yes,
absolutely and this is
why all credit to you,
because in the world of show business,
you have two things, you have
show business friendships,
which are not really friendships.
And then you have actual friendships,
and I considered our relationship
to be a true friendship.
(applause)
Thank you.
- I was not there for shock value.
I was there to share a moment with you
that took on a little
bit of a life of its own,
but my heart was so
well-intended towards you.
- Well, now let's talk
about the circumstance now.
Are you enjoying this part of your life?
- Yeah, as hard and challenging as it is,
I just feel like when I
wake up in the morning,
I wake up to Savannah and Gale.
I go to sleep to people
like you, and you know,
I think of a Jimmy
Fallon, who's like family,
and you guys are who jumpstart
and close out our days.
And that's why I felt so
privileged to step into a role
that has been so important
to me as a citizen
and a human being walking around.
You are literally telling people
it's okay to start their day,
here's how it's going to go,
here's some optimism, here's some news,
here's some information.
And you would say, "You
got through the day,
I'm going to put you to
bed, congratulations.
Now you're allowed to laugh."
- This is a great way
for you to look at it
because it's true, the
landscape in the early morning,
middle of the day, or whenever we see you,
several other people
have helped along the way
have been very beneficial,
Oprah was fantastic.
- So, Dave, do you like being a guest?
- No, no, I'm very uncomfortable about it.
Although, I'm very pleased
about the Zoomer thing.
And I mentioned that was my idea.
- It was good.
- It worked.
- No, because I have nothing,
let me tell you something.
Do I, can I talk, a lot of
places don't want me to talk.
- (giggles) Not here.
- It's interesting about life.
You learn things over
that you already learned,
and then you forget because
you're drawn toward the mundane.
So you can't be sucked into
the reality, the drama,
and the ugliness that
can be provided by life.
So you're drawn toward the mundane
and you learn these
lessons again and again.
And because of the pandemic,
you know people who have had it
and perhaps died, I know
people who have died,
same with all of us.
We're looking at a half a million people.
I don't know how many wars
that is, but a half a million,
stunning that we're living with every day.
So I think humanity is temporary.
And we all know that and
because it's temporary,
we need each other, we more
than ever when you realize
it's temporary need each other.
So I'm trying to be outgoing
and pleasant and helpful
whenever I can.
(applause)
- I always talk about both of your shows
as such like my training
ground, my inspiration,
what I needed in life.
When I would see you
out in your trench coat,
man in the field, I love you both so much,
I honestly live to make you proud.
I mean that with all of my heart,
I can't believe I get to
call you guys my friends.
- Is she going to be all right?
(laughter)
- We love you so much,
and you know what, Drew,
I gotta say thank you
for bringing us together, I
never got to meet Dave Letterman
and now--
- That's right,
Savannah Guthrie, I said, "Oh
yeah, I know Savannah Guthrie"
and then I realized, no, we never did.
- No but we're probably going
to text all the time now
or Zoom.
- Oh yeah, you saw how much
trouble I had with the Zoomer.
- Dave, thank you so much.
This was a great way
to kick off the party.
This was awesome.
Our producer, Kat Kohler
confirmed that the Zoom gag
was all David's idea.
I mean, I love that, I'd love
that he was in on the joke
and coming up with little fun
details on this special day.
What a dream come true,
we'll be right back.
Take a deep dive into
the best of season one!
I'm so in awe that we're
all still so close.
We've experienced everything together.
- [Narrator] And we gear
up for our star studded
two week premiere event.
- In my original hometown of Hollywood!
I grew up here in Los
Angeles, I love it here.
It all starts Monday!
(cheering)
On the next Drew Barrymore show.
Welcome back, right now
I want to highlight a friend of the show.
A member of the Drew's
crew who helped us create
beautiful spaces for some
very wonderful people
throughout season one, call him alumni,
here's the best of celebrity
interior designer: Mikel Welch.
Please welcome, someone I'm such a fan of,
design expert and very
good friend of the show,
masterful artist: Mikel Welch!
- Well hello.
- What I've created for
you ladies are two separate
twin beds, now you needed a headboard.
Didn't want to break the bank,
so there's an easy solution
for this.
I've done a painted headboard
and then you just layer
everything up with a bunch of pillows
and you can complete this
project for less than $30.
- It's so brilliant, Mikel.
- The girls really needed some
additional storage, right?
And so I've given him them a new dresser,
and then I just did a simple mirror
just to kind of balance things off.
And you cannot miss this girl right here.
I mean, the pomp is grass, faux chandelier
is the star of the show.
- Crystal, are those happy tears?
- [Mikel] Aww!
- Mikel, your client is happy.
- I gave you these cute
little planters right here.
And it just allows you an
opportunity to bring all of those,
you know, fresh greenery moments
and to actually display them.
You know, oftentimes we just
push greenery into a corner,
but it's like, no, like
get it up off the floor.
Let us see it!
It's a very Zen like moment.
- Another thing I want to point out that
I was really inspired by,
Mikel, and your choices
was that you echoed the window
treatment to the closet.
- What we were able to do was
to put drapes on the outside
of the closet.
And what that does is, it
does a couple of things.
So first it kind of separates
the space so it doesn't feel
as clutter, but then it's giving
you the optical illusions.
So you kind of feel like
you're in a much bigger space.
- It's super smart.
Well, Natalie and Crystal,
what do you think of the room?
- We love the room, it's amazing.
I like the closet and then
the beds look so good,
this is like amazing.
- Yeah, we finally have our perfect room.
- [Both] Thank you so much.
- I'm super excited to
show you your new room.
- I wish I could give you
a hug, I know I can't.
I'm a hugger, but I know I can't.
- Mikel, I'm really
excited to learn from you
and how you approached this
room and Gloria's closet.
- Okay so, Gloria.
I think the biggest
solution for you was to add
an oversize wardrobe,
which we've done here.
Honey, we have storage and
storage and more storage.
So you see here, we have hanging bar,
so you can get all of your
longer hanging dresses in order.
And then check this out,
we've got all of these rollout bins,
so you know how you
have like your t-shirts
sometimes you roll them up.
Like you can put jeans,
t-shirts everything.
And you look like a bling type of girl,
so I know you're into jewelry.
- Bling, bling, bling, yes!
- So we've even got you jewelry pull out.
So now, everything, two of them.
This a lot of bling, I
gotta control it all here.
Check this out.
- Ooh, beautiful!
- I know right, now can
house every single shoe.
And then last but not least,
over here we gave you some
double hangs so you can
just hang lots of clothes.
You have lots and lots and
lots of storage over here.
- And then did you
personalize the handles?
- I did, I did.
- It looks good!
- So we were putting the design together
and I had just like a pretty
ottoman and Drew was like,
"No, like she needs to
like have some function."
So Drew said she wanted a storage ottoman!
- Love it, that's amazing!
- So now you can have extra storage.
If your husband gets on your nerves,
you can put him in there
too so you're covered!
- Listen, I'm going to lock
my door, padlock on the front,
once it looks beautiful,
nobody's coming in.
- It's beautiful, Mikel!
- So beautiful.
- So amazing, absolutely.
- It's like a dream come
true, thank you so much.
Thank you.
- Aww, I'm glad you like it!
- I cannot wait till our next project.
- Oh my God, you're in my house!
- How does it look?
- Oh my God!
- Mikel is here right now!
- Hey!
I painted it!
- You did that yourself?
- No!
- Girl,
I was about to be really impressed.
- I know!
- We got a little situation with the toys.
I had to donate them, so... I'm joking.
- Oh my God.
(gasp)
Oh my God!
- I love what Mikel did, I
don't think this is a design
by Drew, this is straight up
a design a design by Mikel
I cannot wait to see what
Mikel does in season two
and I'll be right there by his side,
as design is my happy place,
and we'll be right back
with more of our favorite
moments for you right after this.
♪ If you're into fashion
or easy home decor ♪
♪ No stay for recipes,
plus fun celebrities, ♪
♪ Need a little good news ♪
- We're back to bring you more.
♪ Barrymore ♪
♪ Shows all-new for season two ♪
♪ Yeah Barrymore ♪
♪ Life improvin' stain removin' ♪
♪ Barrymore ♪
- [Narrator] The new
season of Drew premieres
September 13th.
- Food! I love eating it!
Talking about it, watching it on TV.
Here is delicious kitchen inspiration.
- Hi Drew! Thanks for
having me back on the show.
Today, I'm going to show
you how to tackle steak.
- It's always better to
season your steak with salt
ahead of time.
A few hours is fine,
but overnight is ideal.
This will allow the salt
penetrate all the way through
to the center of the steak.
Set this on a wire rack and
place it in your fridge.
Uncover for airflow.
If you got an insta pot,
they all come with this
little rack.
How do you know when
your pan is hot enough?
With this hack, you'll
forever get a good sear
on your steak, every single time.
Drop a teaspoon of water into your pan
and when it looks like
T-1000 out of Terminator,
it means your pan is ready.
This is called the Leidenfrost effect,
and if your water sticks and bubbles out,
it means your pan is too
cold and it's not ready.
For New York strips, I
like to add zero oil.
Fat side down first, render out that fat,
and then seer both sides for
about two minutes per side.
When you're ready to butter
bast, turn down the heat to low
because butter burns at high temperatures,
which can leave burnt
bitter taste onto the steak
and butter absolutely loves
aromatics like Thyme and garlic
because they're good buddies
and they infuse really,
really well together.
A digital thermometer is a must.
Always remove the steak 10
degrees lower than your desired
doneness, because the
steak will continue to cook
even when it's out of the pan.
Cover and let it rest.
Resting allows the
muscle proteins to relax
so it can retain more of
it's own juices and flavor.
I like to make a quick sauce
using horseradish, a mustard,
salt, and pepper.
I always cut my steaks at a bias
because it always makes
for a better meat fan.
And finally, don't sleep
on the resting juices.
This is where the magic is at.
Now, watch this move.
Whew, now you tell me if
this will taste good or not.
Mm!
And that's how you cook a steak!
- Wow, I'm in a delicious food
coma just for watching that!
Welcome back.
With everything going on
in the world these days,
we can't lose sight of the
fact that there are real heroes
among us, that's right.
People who do good
things, and on this show,
we like to shine a light on
those we call Drew Gooders.
And one of my favorite was
from season one, 18 year old,
Justin Gavin, from Brooklyn, New York.
We formed a friendship and we
have a payoff for this one.
Take a look.
He saw a burning car on
the street with a mother
and her three children inside
and without hesitation,
he risked his own life to
pull each one of them out
of that burning car into safety.
(applause)
Please welcome right here
in the studio, Justin Gavin.
- Hi!
- I am really star struck
to meet her real life hero.
- I mean, I wouldn't call
myself a hero, I just thought,
I just thought I just did what was right.
So I'm not going to call myself hero.
- But may I ask when you see that,
what goes on inside of your head and body?
Is it a trajectory that just happens?
Are you thinking, what does it feel like?
- To me, I feel like at that
moment it was no thinking.
Like I just thought what was right,
I knew if I was in that situation,
I would definitely want someone
to do exactly what I did,
but not all people was like that,
but I'm just glad I was at the right place
at the right time.
- You really were, so what were you,
you were just walking down
the street on your merry way?
- Yeah, I was, I was running an errand,
and I just saw a bunch of cars
and they were just honking their horns
and they were yelling
out, "The car is on fire,
The cars are fire!" and I was clueless.
I didn't know what was happening.
So I actually did see
the car after a while
and I'm like, "Oh, get out
the car, get out the car.
The car is on fire." and nobody
was running towards the car,
was trying to do anything to help out,
so I just ran towards the car.
- And do you reach in at that
point, do you open doors?
Are, what are you doing?
- I told the oldest,
which is nine years old
to like unbuckle her seatbelt
and her sibling seatbelt.
It was nine, four, and
one, I believe that in the,
it was scary for me cause I didn't know
what was going to happen.
I thought at that time I was
actually going to lose my life
and they were gonna lose their life.
But if I did lose my life
I would lose my life trying
to save somebody else
so it was... (applause)
- I mean, do you believe in angels?
- Yeah, I do, I do.
A lot of people call me an angel,
but I just feel like I
just did the right thing.
- You really are an
angel and I mean, I just,
I believe there are humans
masquerading as angels.
I believe that there
is capacity in a human,
but to sit here and
hear your story, I mean,
you are what I think
people need to believe in.
We need to believe in
angels in human form.
I just, okay.
So everyone ended up okay?
- Yeah, everybody ended
okay, the mom at one point
she couldn't really breathe correctly,
but the paramedics helped
her out, gave her more oxygen
so she can actually
start breathing correctly
and she was just grateful
that I was there.
The kids was grateful.
It was, I was just happy
that they was all safe,
I'm glad that I was safe.
I'm glad everybody at that
area in the area was safe.
Nobody really got harmed but.
- You saved an entire
family, I just, I'm sorry.
I'm really, I am just in awe of you
and the mayor of Waterbury, Connecticut.
When, where this happened,
when he heard what you did,
he wanted to do something for you.
So he asked me to give
you this proclamation
of the town in honor of your bravery.
And that's not all, when we
heard that you had a particular
favorite basketball player,
he also heard what you did.
And he had this to say,
it's Carmelo Anthony.
- What?
- Yo, Justin.
It's Carmelo Anthony here, bruh.
I heard about your story,
man, I wanted to let you know
how inspiring and courageous you are, man.
You a true, true hero.
You've inspired me, man, and
I'm so inspired to have someone
like you supporting me
throughout my career.
I appreciate it more than you even know.
I also heard you're a
sneaker head like me,
so we're going to hook you
up with some Jordan brands,
as a small thank you for the big things
that you've been doing, man,
and that you continue to do it.
So, you know, I leave you with this,
you know, just keep pushing,
man, keep persevering,
keep making your family proud.
Again, thank you for what you did
and just know we all rooting for you, man,
and know you're going to
continue to do great things.
Peace.
Stay mellow.
- We also found out that you're
a fan of the Brooklyn Nets
and they wanted to say, thank you too!
So!
- Oh, this is so-- (laughs)
- So we have hooked you all up.
We're getting you season
passes, go to all the games,
the players are excited to meet you.
And really there's just not
enough that we can do here
at this show, there's no
way to sort of monetize
or match your act of
saving an entire family.
But we just wanted to start in some way
and everybody joined in and
we just are in awe of you
honestly, thank you, Justin.
- Thank you so much.
- Thank you Justin!
Yeah, you're going to see
Justin back on our show
in season two, because we're
both going to get our GEDs.
Hoo, I'm nervous, we'll be right back.
Welcome back in one of
our very first episodes,
I admitted something about myself.
I'm a stan for stains and
on this show, stain removal
isn't a chore, it's an art form.
See what I mean in our very
first Stan for Stain segment,
I have a secret obsession
and it is with stains.
No, in fact, I Stan for Stains.
And the reason I messed that up is because
Stan is a new word to me.
Apparently it means stalker and fan,
it was kind of originated by Eminem so
I'm definitely going with that.
So I'm a Stan for Stains,
the bigger, the tougher,
the stickier, the better, I'm a mom,
so this was like kind of perfect.
My passion works.
I love concocting the
perfect solutions, products,
combinations, treatments, methodologies,
tools are very important.
Process is important.
So I asked some people to
send me in their stains
and then I'm going to help
them figure out how to fix it.
Let's see how this goes, okay.
First, Julia sent us a video, take a look.
- Hi Drew, my name is Julia
Morales and I'm from Chicago,
Illinois and I need your help.
Girl, you have no idea, I love to party,
I had a really great party,
but a couple of friends
of mine have spilled
some fruit punch on my carpet
and I'm supposed to be moving.
And my landlord said
he's going to charge me
if I don't get that stain up.
I have no idea how to get this out.
Draw, please, please,
please, please help me.
- Okay, first of all, Julia,
we both know that that isn't juice.
And second of all, if it's really wine,
I need to know that because
it takes a different method,
but let's just pretend it's juice.
Here is everybody's first
mistake, in my opinion.
If you get stuff in your carpet,
do not leave it till the next day.
You want to have it be wet
because that's how the absorption happens.
Don't think, "Oh, I'll attack that later.
You won't! It's set in at that point!
You can still fix it, make
it a part of the party.
Hey, I'm still grooving and talking,
but I'm doing this at the same time, okay?
Like the fun doesn't have to stop, I mean,
as far as I'm concerned,
the fun just started.
But seriously, like don't think
that's a next day project.
I'm not a righteous person,
but I'm kind of righteous about stains.
Don't push on it!
Lift!
Absorb!
You want to gently tap
a very absorbent thing.
When people go in and
start doing this, I'm like.
(Drew screams)
So this, I am literally, I am like,
it's like a Bunny's paw on cotton.
You're going to pat kind of
like, you're the bunny going
Like, "Hey, I want some
of that, like, hey."
Then you can take a
multitude of stain removals.
So I'm going to take my trusty draft.
Also don't put a ton of stuff on a stain,
like be gentle with it.
It's like, you know, think baby bunny,
when it comes to stains,
how are we looking?
Thank you, this is important to me.
I'm single, I live with my two children,
and how I party and get
off in my free time is
I kill stains, okay.
So if you have one I'm
interested, all right,
I want to party, let's do this.
Michael, I understand you have a scene.
Show me what you got.
- Hey Drew, my name is Michael Red
and I'm a real estate agent
from Whippany, New Jersey
and I love eating ice cream.
Unfortunately, when I eat ice cream,
I get a little bit into
it and I wound up staining
my favorite white shirt
with chocolate ice cream.
I need get this stain out,
I don't know what to do,
Drew, I need some help.
- Listen, it happens, this is
nothing, chocolate is nothing.
Again, this is why, yeah, that's right!
The graft is coming back out.
All right, now this time
I'm going to treat the draft
very differently.
I mean, this is like literally
finding your soulmate,
I'm not kidding.
I love you.
Oh, Cherie, you sets my soul on fire.
That's what I do to my
daughter Olive all the time,
it's from a Tom and Jerry cartoon.
And she goes, "Mom!"
Probably 'cause, you know,
I don't know about you,
but I just live to embarrass my children.
So I'm just using my finger tip.
(laughter)
So at this point, if you
want, you can start to gently,
again, think bunny.
So I'm trying to make
this go a little faster,
'cause we have a lot of other
things to accomplish today,
but I am in my happy place right now.
Here's another tip.
The fibers actually can
work as an abrasiveness
so you can actually
start to rub it together.
If you don't have a toothbrush
handy, water in the bowl.
Excellent, okay.
This is pure water, ooh, it's warm too.
Oh!
All right now normally, I
would put this under a big,
running faucet, wring it
dry and then present you
with your shirt.
I want you to find that
chocolate, God darn it.
That's right, that's right.
Bring me your stains,
I want the challenge!
This is my happy place, bring it on,
what have you got for me?
(applause)
Look, maybe I need to go get
a life, but you know what?
I don't care.
I love stain removal,
I do Stan for Stains.
Since that first Stan
for Stain segment aired,
we've removed spaghetti
sauce, marshmallow stickiness,
grease, barbecue sauce, popsicles,
green juice out of Michael
Strand's suit and so much more.
And I can't wait to see what stains
we're going to tackle in season two.
I won't have to wait long because
it's less than a week away.
Oh, stains you better watch out!
Don't go anywhere,
there's more show up next.
Welcome back, we're looking
back on our favorite moments
from season one of the
Drew Barrymore show.
And just before the break, we
saw me stan for some stains.
Well, in this moment from last season,
I'm stanning for even more cleaning
and organizing solutions.
It's for the fridge and we
had a mom who's TikTok video
of her organizing the
snack drawer in her fridge
racked up over 26 million views.
And I still follow her,
she changed my life
and game, meet Monica Brady.
TikTok is a goal of mine for
the latest trends and tricks.
And even that includes cleaning.
Okay, this is so exciting, I can't wait.
One woman racked up 26 million
views, her hypnotic video,
of her cleaning and
restocking the snack drawer
of her fridge.
- I could watch this all day long.
- No, it's so brilliant.
She's a mom from Michigan
who cleans and calms
with every TikTok video she posts,
and guess what, Rassie?
- What?
- She's here!
- (melodically) I know!
- Please welcome Monica Brady!
- Hi Monica, hi!
- Oh my gosh, I'm so excited
to be here with you guys.
- Oh, we feel the same way about you
and what an impressive thing
that you've done, Monica,
procuring millions and
millions, not like three,
four or five, I'm talking like 25,
30 million people are
watching your videos.
Why do you think that
they're so hypnotizing
and people are so drawn to them?
What's the secret?
- So I just really feel like
with ASMR and cleaning videos,
at least this is the feedback
that I've gotten from
like my followers is they're
really motivating for people.
Like they'll be after dinner
and there'll be, you know,
relaxing and enjoying their
meal and, and they're like,
"Oh, I just came across this
TikTok and she's, you know,
organizing her fridge or
she's cleaning something."
And it just really motivates my followers
and they reach out to me
and they just love it.
And it just motivates them,
and I just love producing
this kind of content for
people because of that.
- Well, it motivated me, I have to say,
I watched your video and then
I attacked my refrigerator.
I really did, this weekend,
and I like cleaned it
and turned all the labels forward
because you gave me a refrigerator envy.
But for people who think
that they can't do that,
where do we start?
- Hmm, good question.
- Start small would be my
biggest piece of advice.
And if anybody's new and
starting an organization,
I would really recommend just
like mapping out your fridge.
Like where do you want the produce to go?
Where do you want the drinks to go?
Where do you want the snacks to go?
Just if everything is right up
front and just easy to grab,
like the produce is washed,
you know how many drinks do you have,
you know what drinks you have.
There's less likely to
be waste in the fridge
and there's less likely to
be waste of food as well.
At least that's how it is in our home,
that we've, you know,
everything gets eaten
for the most part.
- Yeah, if you can see
it, you don't waste it,
it makes sense.
- Right, right.
- No, it's not just refrigerators, okay.
Right, you also went viral
for a little laundry hack?
Tell us about that.
- It did, so back
beginning of COVID actually
my husband and I redid our laundry space
and he put a shelf up
above the washer and dryer
and I put all my laundry
products up there and I was like,
this is really disappointing
because the laundry containers
are ugly, and I found these
gorgeous glass containers,
glass jars, they're actually
like beverage dispensers.
- Yeah, yeah, like you would
put lemonade or Iced Tea
in one of these.
- I think they're actually
advertised as an Iced Tea
dispenser and there were only $6.
I'm like, "Oh, this is awesome."
- That's such a brilliant idea,
so you don't have like
this neon jug on display,
you can have this cute little thing.
- And then one day I
just decided, you know,
I'm like, "Hey, I'm going to film this.
I feel like it's something
TikTok would like."
And it completely blew
up, and that's where
my TikTok platform started actually.
- Well, Monica, what I love
about what you're doing
is that it's leading
functionality and tips
and ways to organize
and make life prettier,
I am so into what you're doing,
I'm so happy that it's
getting so much recognition
and I understand.
- Yeah, I feel like I've learned
so much from you, Monica.
Thanks for all these tips.
- Oh my gosh, I'm fangirling so much
because I love both of you
and you guys like literally
watch my TikToks, I'm so excited!
- Well, Monica, come back
and teach us more, seriously!
- Oh, anytime!
Anytime!
- Here are some pictures of my fridge
because she has literally changed my life
and I love it and she improved it.
And that's what happens here
on this show, and I love it.
It's what I call #fridgegoals.
And we'll be right back
with some more inside info
about next season, including
our premier show guests.
Huh, it's a good one.
Don't move.
Take a deep dive into
the best of season one!
I'm so in awe that we're
all still so close.
We've experienced everything together.
- [Narrator] And we gear
up for our star studded
two week premiere event!
- In my original hometown of Hollywood!
I grew up here in Los Angeles.
I love it here, it all starts Monday.
(cheering)
On the next Drew Barrymore show.
Welcome back, we are less than a week away
from kicking off season two
of the Drew Barrymore show!
Our big premier will be none
other than Jennifer Aniston!
(Drew squeals)
I could not be more
excited to talk to her.
We actually were in a movie together,
He's Just Not That Into You.
And we have a very good friend
in common, Mr. Adam Sandler.
And I got to ask her about
the morning show because, ugh,
it is just one of my favorites,
but everything she does is my favorite.
She's Jennifer Aniston.
Plus, while we're in my
hometown of Los Angeles,
I'll be taking you all
on a tour of the places
that mean most to me.
The house I grew up in, my
very first apartment at 14,
and I'm revisiting some other places
that might come as a
surprise that I'm actually
revealing them, but I need
them to be an invitation to you
so that we can embrace
everything that's happened
in our lives and be proud
of where it has brought us.
It's happening all next week on season two
of the Drew Barrymore show.
See you soon!